like you just ask yourself a logical
question if Hunter Biden is a crackhead
I'm sure a lot of people could have
easily predicted we'll eventually find
drugs in the White House hey it happened
now we're supposed to believe it was not
Hunter he's the notorious famous drug
user so look maybe maybe it's only a
five percent chance it was Hunter yeah
he still has the the dominant plurality
of probability The Narrative is already
set either way like it doesn't really
matter if Hunter did have it or not
because it's not likely that there's
going to be any kind of significant
investigation the people on the right
have already made up their mind that it
was Hunter they're gonna say it was
Hunter and meme the hell out of it even
if it kind of sucks regards on him at
this point because he's getting blamed
for it anyway right I mean he's already
but he look there's there's video of him
smoking crack on his way to Las Vegas
driving 100 no no was it the same one
where he was driving 172 miles he was I
mean I heard the crack in the car was
different than the driving 107. does it
matter